welcome to this video playing Radha hua
from Romania Romania on Kings Indian
maybe maybe I can do something here ok
it's not playing D for that some quite
uncommon ok then i'm going to play d 5
yeah it's a very weird form of isolated
pawn how does he even protect the poor
now and quite clear yeah well this but
that's not c4 Wow ok ok I'll take it and
let's see ya then does this more than
one good ye five now is one of them a 5d
5e for Mike there's also bishop age 6
not too bad ok um what exactly am i
playing though Queenie five okay maybe
just completing development slowly the
bishop is not going away at some
long-term thing and okay here's a for
this kind of center but if he is
actually playing it for his [ __ ] for
porn at the dark squares are immensely
week yeah this is this is funny the team
that he actively seeks the Queen trade
in this and this position where he is
fighting fighting the bishops and
interesting
okay he's opened up the long diagonal
though that's a that's true and night c
5s it's a possibility okay if I go b6
that's probably not great okay let's do
that I'm not quite sure what's the best
way to play it d5 night b4 should be
quite okay h who hangs d5 hangs and this
also 93 some somewhere yeah okay this
this is the only critical looking move
so take here or not
I can also play b6 but then you will
take it's not clear that this is leading
to anything let's go here actually why
not that's not that attacking of the
rook and term night b7 there is Luke be
aid and I win an exchange okay maybe you
can make a sacrifice out of it with
other than that I will play b6 next I
also take d5 here okay he's making the
sacrifice out of it as described okay I
didn't really appreciate these six this
is quite strong really hmm not that
that's not clear at all that's very very
quickly spawn okay what do I do here I
think I mean it would be excellent if I
would manage to play you for just
killing this Bishop and this is what I'm
trying to do I just got 83 and I know in
some way you're taking the night III
route 93 should be five check and then
look on the seventh or something like
that now it's a fairly unclear okay here
34 would be good he can promote
yeah anyway I need to do it anyway Kier
thought I mean this should be quite okay
my remaining pieces are very active and
this bishop on g2 is of course quite bad
okay grab this cannot go to a one
because of this very long diagonal
should as flick in this chick a skinny
29 upgrade so here and if I get in rook
d3 i'll attack b3 it's not so clear how
it protects it ya can only protect it
with a very passive move like you will
be one do you really don't want to do
yeah I already suspected that he
wouldn't play that okay um but and do I
want no we're not ready i want could get
this i want to keep active pieces he I
don't want to grab now now maybe 95 was
even stronger where this is ok this is
okay it just keeps total control here
III Hanks and that's 95 to III as a
possibility okay 95 maybe just trying to
get this pawn I cannot take here I can
go here though intending Knight c3 maybe
yeah it's not clear-cut we know anything
I don't see it at least maybe just
Bishop c5 actually yeah okay or this
wait wait this is even stronger right
yeah 93 was strong but this is stronger
just winning winning everything can you
have 193 yeah I am this was strange a
bit because I thought I was a bit
surprised how quickly he he now went for
this because after you for I'm really
killing his pieces so I thought that he
really needed to play and here he needed
to play I don't know a three or
something maybe it's not working but
what one is there a big problem I can
play me for anyway and in fact I can do
that the idea of a three would be that
in a move like that he will play this
and this for example and white is
clearly better yeah the computer
confirms that okay so I am Mia I I
needed to find here efore and okay maybe
I would have managed but during the game
I didn't see that and this is in fact
still okay for me now this Hank so
something like that is going to happen
with a good game for black but I need I
need to see it still so it was a bit a
bit strange that he played these seven
because after that it's pretty clear
that now only black can be better now my
pieces are much much more active and I
win this pawn Jim Jim and here this is
some just threatening this and rugby
three this is luis dallas but it was
probably already lost the compass on
minus three so the the the real um the
point was here he shouldn't shouldn't
allow that as mentioned but in general
the whole concept what the bid we had to
give up the the dark squared bishop and
then trade down to an end game well
maybe he has enough active counter play
with 95 but this is the kind of position
if black I can move let's say I know
this is fictional two times in a row and
I go will XA be six rook c8 then right
is just clearly worse against the
bishops better structure terrible
position but this okay I'll the computer
also gives me a clear GM so I probably
probably played it right so okay I hear
interesting it wants to play with ships
e8 maybe this is the the farm or engine
the far easier way to play yeah this is
actually very strong this Bishop is just
retweeting to cover the only weakness
that black hairs I'm attacking here I'm
attacking on a2 and yeah he don't he
doesn't really have a booth I can just
take him and return after that yeah that
just just was very bad for white that
have possibilities to activate the
bishop as well and this was was much
stronger even alright thanks for
watching